but listen yes you know I could you know
and it's so fun I'm so glad that you're
here because I don't know why we haven't
done this soon I'll be honest yeah I
don't know why we didn't do this sooner
because I feel like you and I could do
this for hours
sparks will fly I see the bags under
your eyes right they formed while we
were they did it wasn't here before they
were here no his bags just won't because
of him you know the excess baggage she's
feeling you know emotional about you
know me and some of the things yeah
right but at the end of the day I tell
you another thing you did for me yeah
when I went to New York you called st
from the Comedy Cellar
yep and you said see Bobby Lee you set
up a showcase for me and she saw me on a
Friday I did good you know she passed me
but like I can I would only go to
someone like you for those kind of
favors because I know that you'll
actually pull through for me and at the
end of the day um you could be in my top
five of all time in comedy people I can
you go to your myspace yeah so um that's
you know that's I do want to throw that
out but next time you have a job and you
think you I I should be in it yes get me
the job first and then tell me yes I
agree with that yeah look and I agree
with that I think that there are things
that I could have done better personally
because I think when you were when
you're given the opportunity to
green-light or whatever you just reach
out to people yeah and you have a deep
affection for go oh my god I love to
include you but then the business comes
into play with it and you realize oh
it's not as easy as just you know but I
don't think that I'm and I'll be honest
with you just to defend myself I don't
think I'm that tough of a sell you are
no joke no because people have like you
know I was on splitting up together this
ABC show I didn't test
I didn't audition they just gave it to
me right so I know how people in power
feel about me I've been in many
situations like that I just want to
defend myself right yeah so I you know
I'm just want to say that you know I
don't think I'm at that big of a sell so
but I know that there are political
things that
I'm not privy to that I'm not gonna take
personal anymore and just I will do
whatever with you I would to the end of
my life if you want to do something with
me I'll [ __ ] do it I'll memorize my
lines I'll be on [ __ ] it I'll show up
and we'll do it alright and let's just
bury the hatchet with everything okay I
don't ever want to say it again okay in
other podcasts yeah we're ending it now
whatever because there's a lot of purity
yeah goodness
yeah it comes from you yeah I mean I
haven't talked about you at all
but you're the one that talks about me
so when you're saying we bury the
hatchet it you better you better you did
okay let me rephrase this the screencap
of it let me rephrase that you better
ask it and this is what it is okay yes I
you could have just let it go at that
and then we could have just a mob moved
under the next thing right yeah but then
you had to add in right you bare you
know whatever that's what it sounded
okay but you bury the hatchet where
where have you ever been where you're
like word on the street is burns talk
and [ __ ] on like where's that doesn't
have more of a Rat Pack style perhaps
ship but I don't like Sebastian
Maniscalco in that way you guys have
like a real like huh I just keep to
myself like a team
yeah they don't you know me you don't
rat your friends out you know like mafia
style right he has those things and I'm
the guy that dies the five minutes right
I get stabbed a thousand times by pencil
okay just in the first five minutes in
the movie that's yeah because I'm a
talker yeah I'm a coward right but you
know you know I'm okay yeah but let us
bury it now I'll bury the hatchet okay
since you know we don't have a hatchet
I'll bury the hatchet yeah I'll bear for
life okay and then you and I can move on
yes right but you know watch it I'm not
afraid did you know you know I love you
though that's what you're here were we
you know I love you listen you have you
do know that correct the fact that he
does get especially triggered by you
because I think he has a deeper love for
you than he has
compared to other people because when he
had you guys had that weird thing at the
Comedy Store you came back home crying
yeah and you don't cry about people
that's how hurt me I'm not I'm not
making it up right right yeah these are
things that I get really down about
right and I can die it really affects me
it hurts
right I suffer but to be fair it you
shouldn't air it out on a podcast if
some girl fight it